all right it's time for a culture whip
around with the one and only raymond
arroyo fox news contributor
raymond i want to start with this
federal judge ruling against the college
of the ozarks which is a christian
school last year the college challenged
a hud memo
that would allow biological male
students to live in female dorms but the
recent ruling by the u.s court of
appeals essentially gives the green
light to the co-ed
for a co-ed college dorms in the name of
honoring gender identity
i don't think parents are paying tens of
thousands of dollars to send their kids
off to a mixed gender playground but
what say you
well they might be jason we have to see
but look all of this stems from a biden
executive order and in it he basically
equated sex with gender identity so
statutes title ix that was put there to
protect girls from sexual bias in hiring
in the workplace and education
that they've applied that now to anyone
identifying as female or as male if
you're a female biologically so you know
we're talking about co-ed accommodations
in college how about no ed
accommodations because the focus here is
clearly not on education dorms were
created to give these students safety
and a place where they could be study
and be educated in a safe environment
that's out the window when you start
allowing biological meals into a female
dormitory at a christian school the
other layer here is all of the religious
exemptions have been removed blown out
by joe biden here and that also needs
some careful scrutiny
now the religious liberty and the idea
that you could send your
your son or your daughter into a school
and that they have rules or or that they
can make their own decisions but to
force this is just crazy all right we
got to move on uh hollywood they have a
new trend surprise surprise making
excuses more and more actors are using
their
mental health to get out of obligations
jonah hill for instance was told
deadline you won't see me out there
promoting these
this the
films or any of my upcoming films while
i take this important step step to
protect myself
yeah jason your actor tom holland made a
similar announcement this week uh on
social media watch i have taken a break
from social media uh
for my mental health because i find
instagram and twitter to be over
stimulating to be
overwhelming i get caught up and i
spiral when i read things about me
online
and ultimately it's very detrimental to
to my mental state
it probably affects all of our mental
health all this social media don't you
think
yeah well look tom holland he's got a
point there and any young person
grappling with social media look it's
narcissistic it's nasty
i appreciate him saying you know what
i'm going to step back from this for my
own well-being that's perfectly
acceptable but when you get into major
stars
actors who's part of their job is to
promote the film that they've been paid
a lot of money to star in when they
begin to opt out of working exciting
their anxiety jason i don't know about
you but i get anxious every morning i'm
sure heart surgeons get anxious before
they go into surgery but you don't drop
the tools and walk out of the operating
room i mean you have to stay in the game
and do your job uh sean mendy's the uh
the big
singer he's out on a concert tour guy's
worth 40 million dollars he's suspending
the tour because he says
the tour makes him anxious the road
makes a matrix he said this it has
always been difficult to be on the road
away from friends and family well try a
military deployment multiple times and
call us in the morning i mean come on
yeah jason
yeah you're away from your family for
months at a time years at a time in some
cases jason i know you touched on the
border earlier we actually have a
breaking update i need to share with you
this is a fox news alert the wall is
finally going up the department of
homeland security just announced at
taxpayers expense a half million dollar
wall will be built around joe biden's
beach house in rehoboth beach in
maryland
whoa that's all you were looking for
yes i'm glad to go there but i thought
joe biden said they weren't going to
spend a penny on the on the wall
yeah this is the man who stopped the the
construction of the wall in the yuma
region arizona is paying for its own uh
you know paying millions of dollars to
fill three thousand feet of gaps in that
wall and meanwhile joe biden gets a tax
payer ride for his own little uh wall
around the house i hope they put a moat
in as well just to be sure he and jill
are really safe
well if walls protect people that's what
they should be doing right but i think
that hypocrisy is just studying look we
want the president and former presidents
to be safe but come on protecting our
country that would be a good thing too
yeah national security takes a little
precedence over beach security just a
little bit when the taxpayer is footing
the bill
yeah very good raymond arroyo you're the
best thank you so much for joining us
tonight hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else